being honest even when it sucks because  let me tell you how many times it's  gonna be where if you  just lied oh god it would be so much  easier  and you would probably get away with it  and  but it the way that i explain lying to  people is  you get away with it 50 of the time and  so it tempts you to think it's a good  strategy  but the other 50 of the time it is  cratering trust  and once you can't trust the person all  hope is lost and  there's nothing more beautiful than  being in a relationship with somebody  who makes you feel like they're your  number  their number one and that you totally  trust them  and lisa wrote this um instagram post  about how  she could see a photo of me with my arm  around a woman or resting my head i'm  swimming or hugging her or whatever  and she it wouldn't even make her radar  to question it  so that's the fun for us  is having that level of trust